now before i announce the nominees for
best live action show
i've got a question for the nominees
here can i get a quick show of hands
how many of you started off your career
working as cast or crew
on a short film
i'm noticing some of the people go
straight to the top um
exactly i mean look you can always be
sure the category for best live action
short
will showcase some of tomorrow's great
filmmakers and you can understand why
building a world drawing an audience
into it taking them
on an unforgettable ride over an hour or
two is difficult enough
to do in under 20 minutes is a miracle
if feature films are novels short films
are like poems
they have less space to work with but
the distilled vision they contain can
often make even more of an impact
here are the nominees for best live
action short film
feeling through doug roland and susan
rosenski
the letter elvira lind and sofia
sondavan
the present fara nablusi and osama
bawardi
two distant strangers trayvon free and
martin des monroe
white eye sommer
and the oscar goes to two distant
strangers
trayvon free and martin desmond
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my god
[Applause]
oh god it's so good oh hi oh
today the police will kill three people
and tomorrow the police will kill three
people
and the day after that the police will
kill three people because
on average the police in america every
day kill three people
which amounts to about a thousand people
a year
and those people happen to
disproportionately black people
and you know james baldwin once said
the most despicable thing a person can
be is indifferent to other people's pain
and so i just ask that you please not be
indifferent
please don't be indifferent to our pain
we'd like to thank netflix for giving
our short film the chance to be seen by
the world
we'd like to thank the academy for
championing the art of the short film
we'd like to thank joey badass andrew
howard and zaria
for bringing our short film to life and
we'd like to bring we'd like to thank
lauren spender sean combs chris weiler
jesse williams
nick may van latham mickey meyer james
samuels and nick through
for making this dream a reality
and i want to thank tony my mom and
zaria happy birthday baby i love you
thank chelsea my mom and my brother love
you too thank you all
you